This morning, I got up and got ready quickly because I have to get a lot of stuff done.
I sat down at my desk to start getting my stuff done...
...and I spilled my coffee so I got a sponge to clean it up.
And I figured I'd take an extra minute to clean the whole desk...
...because a clean desk would help me get my stuff done.
When I was finished, I realized I hadn't eaten anything...
...and I didn't wanna be hungry while I got my stuff done.
So I went into the kitchen and I was out of cereal.
When I got into the grocery store, I remembered a bunch of other crap I needed to get.
And I figured I was already there so I did my shopping for the week...
...so I didn't have to worry about it while I got my stuff done.
When I got home, I didn't feel like cereal anymore and so I made an omelet...
...and I did the dishes so I wouldn't have to do them after I got my stuff done.
And then I went out to get some oil from the hardware store...
...because my desk chair is kind of squeaky...
...and I didn't want to be distracted by a squeaky chair while I got my stuff done.
When I got back it was getting kind of late...
...and I knew I wouldn't be able to get my stuff done today...
...so I started watching the Twilight Zone marathon on TV.
I just have to make sure I get to bed early because I want to be well rested tomorrow...
...so I can get my stuff done.